foreign
[Music]
y'all it is straight up gorgeous out
today in DC it's like 63 degrees so how
about we go do some dance yeah Drex here
from DirectX Factor POI sharing with you
the love of poi spinning and flow Arts
to benefit your body and brain and today
I want to teach you some things about
dancing with those three beet leaves but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and a special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel Johnny Howard
Lane machinski and Becca beckonen thank
you all so very much for your support
from my work and my mission so like
three weaves are just deceptively hard
to dance with right I mean we have our
two beat weaves in which case we can
literally just put one beat of the POI
on One Beat of the Music but they look
kind of lopsided don't they whereas if
we go with our three beat weaves which
actually looks symmetrical we wind up in
a place where we now have too many beats
to work with and we're going to have to
do a lot of them in order to catch up
with the music you know three doesn't
divide into four very easily at all now
there are some people that do teach that
method for dancing with three wheels but
I'm not one of them I think that three
beat weaves are more useful as an accent
tool I covered this a bit in my video on
musicality a couple months ago but long
and short of it is that I think that
there's a lot more to be gained in terms
of dancing to the music by accenting
what's going on with your hands instead
of the POI themselves
um
so let's dive into some examples shall
we okay so let's start pretty basic and
then work our way up now um I know that
I'm primarily talking about three beat
weaves in this video but I would be
remiss if I didn't also include
information on two beat weaves so uh
this is actually something that did for
a piece of choreography for my POI dance
class a little while ago I had us play
around with the idea of doing a two beat
that is accompanied with a step out to
the side so if I cross left over I step
to the right I cross right over I step
to the left so let me let me show you
this with music right quick all right so
check it
five six seven eight one we go over two
we go over three we go over four we go
over
[Music]
so that's like relatively
straightforward it doesn't take a lot of
dance prowess in order to make that work
you just have to be able to step on the
beat yeah and of course those two beat
weaves are helping you do it it's just a
matter of timing things up so that you
cross your hands on the beat and cross
your hands on the beat that's it okay
but can we do this with three beat
weaves after all we have that extra beat
to work with now so when we cross over
we're now crossing right back over yeah
short answer is yes but it's kind of
tricky okay so option number one here
would be that you just take a step every
time you cross one hand over the other
and actually this isn't bad if you say
want to take that same idea from our two
beat weaves and do it in double time for
example
so that works but it's also pretty quick
the other option would be if you say
want to wait every other time that you
have a hand crossing over so I do right
hand but I'm going to wait not then but
I'm going to take the next time that the
left goes over not then but the next
time the right goes over not then but
the next time the left goes over you see
I'm kind of hanging out for a second
rather than taking the step instantly
and that gives me a little bit of
breathing room there
thank you
so these two options definitely work but
they're definitely not my favorite
either part of the reason being that
we're basically keeping our hands in
this small little T-Rex place and I like
being able to give our POI volume when
we so choose it's also at this point
that I'm going to switch us from doing
things in a wheel plane orientation to
doing things in a wall plane orientation
as I'm doing this you'll note that I'm
basically just switching into waist
wraps because that's just kind of how
things go with the three beat weave when
you put it in wall plane if you don't
have your reverse weaves and waist
straps down just yet that's okay I'll
include tutorials to both of those
things down in the description but just
know that is now the territory that
we're exploring all right and from this
position right here honestly one of the
simplest things that we can do is we can
just pivot from one side to the other on
the beat you notice how I'm making my
hand movements here pretty sharp in
order to hit either side of that move
let's listen to that with some music
yeah
[Music]
yeah I'm not gonna lie sticking on the
beat on this one can be a little bit of
a challenge not the least of which
because again we have that problem where
we're dealing with three downbeats to
the POI instead of an even number so as
we're kind of hanging out here we kind
of have to like pull ourselves really
rapidly from one end to another we
basically have to almost skip a beat of
the POI in order to make that work
so it can work but it might be a little
bit challenging we can also of course
play around a little bit with our volume
and this might be something that works
for those of you that don't have your
reverse weaves or your waist straps down
just yet as you're performing a three
beat weave you know how on each side of
your body there's that place where your
arms kind of separate for a second where
you're unwrapping and re-wrapping your
hands now I can either like exaggerate
that a little bit or I can exaggerate
that a whole lot like so
and this also becomes a tool for us in
how we put this weave to music too
[Music]
now as you can see I can do a lot of
stuff with my body in there too from say
like taking steps boom when I go big all
the way to when I say switch to a side I
can use that as a moment to say
introduce a little bit of lateral body
movement all of these things work well
and I hope you're seeing like I do that
adding a little bit of volume to this
also adds a lot of visual interest to it
as well and of course I would be remiss
if I didn't include perhaps my favorite
use of the three beat weave in POI dance
so this is where it becomes helpful to
know that when we perform fountains what
we're really just doing is performing
waist wraps where we're adding up and
down motion we go down and around we go
up and over and well we can do that as
we're turning our bodies too so the
simplest version of this is to just turn
your body around as you're performing
that Fountain another option would be to
turn that into a pirouette or my
favorite option you can turn that into a
torgate and do a jump with it like so so
let's check out all these options with
music shall we
[Music]
thank you
cool so I hope that gave y'all out there
some ideas of what you can do with your
own three beat weaves as you're dancing
with them if you've got anything out of
this video please make sure to like
comment share and subscribe help other
people find it help keep the
conversation going and of course help my
channel grow oh yeah and if y'all out
there have your own particular things
that you like doing with three beat
weaves as you're dancing please leave me
a comment and let me know I would love
to see what other options that you all
out there have found yourselves
foreign
[Music]
my hair is a mess now that'll happen
when dancing though uh anyhow this video
would not be possible if not for the
kind support of all of these lovely
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon and they along
the people listed down in the
description helped to make this video
and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all so very
much for your very very generous support
and if you out there watching uh like
these videos and are not currently
supporters and would like to become
supporters you can do that by heading on
over to patreon.com directs Factor POI
and signing up there you can get access
to a whole host of awesome rewards and
even better you'll be helping me out in
my mission to bring POI spinning and
flow Arts to the whole wide world and
making a lot of people happy in the
process so go check that out please and
thank you if you'd like to check out
some of my other videos on POI dancing I
will go ahead and leave a playlist link
down in the description as well as up
here on screen if you are watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video based upon your past viewing
habits so maybe give that a look-see as
well thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today use these
tips and I'll see you with a new video
real soon
peace